[Musique]
crépitement note chaleureuse si vous
entendez de la musique rue Maurice Berto
à Conflant saint-onorine alors ça vient
probablement du Viny vintage studio
cette boutique c'est le paradis des
méloman Viny instrument de musique cours
de guitare ou encore concert les samedi
soir ce disquer a ouvert ses portes il y
a un an imaginé et conçu par Arnaud
George il nous fait la visite j'ai créé
un lieu où on voulait on pouvait trouver
à peu près tout sur la musique donc vous
pouvez à l'entrée de la boutique avoir
tout ce qui est des goodies les
vêtements au milieu de la boutique vous
avez tout ce qui est Viny d'occasion qui
se trouve au milieu tous les accessoires
pour les instruments après si ici vous
avez tout ce qui qui est Viny neuf tout
un mural pour les vinyes neuf et là vous
avez aussi tous les instruments de
musique donc guitare batterie clavier
ici au fond et tous les accessoires nous
avons aussi une scène qui tourne une
fois par semaine le samedi de 18h à 19h
vous avez ici chez nous deux studios de
répétition sont des studios que je loue
au groupes qui viennent répéter le soir
essentiellement j'ai beaucoup de groupes
qui vienent répéter le soir de entre 19h
et 22h mais la journée ces studios sont
utilisés par des professeurs en fait
vous êtes un peu une boutique et une
école un peu tout quoi voilà c'est ça en
fait pour tout vous dire je voulais
créer un endroit qui me ressemble et
comme j'aurais aimé le trouver quand
j'étais plus jeune et cette boutique
c'était la surprise pour les conflanis
d'autant plus pour les jeunes qui
raffolent des disques vinyes depuis 7
ans la demande augmente et en 2023 les
moins de 35 ans représentent près de 60
% des acheteurs quand j'ai vu ça il y a
un an une boutique de vinyes qui ouvre
dans ma ville moi j'étais super content
parce que moi j'adore les viniles donc
là plus besoin d'aller loin quand semb
bat de chez soi quoi bon mon fils adore
tout ce qui est Viny il il aime beaucoup
la musique bien souvent ces cadeaux bah
c'est ça hein c'est du vinil hein pour
pour les anniversaires pour les fêtes je
trouve ça cool de pouvoir en trouver
d'occasions plutôt que d'acheter sur des
sites et en ayant du neuf donc là ouais
c'est sympa de pouvoir un peu aussi
zuter en direct et tout ça quoi
alors Régine est-ce que vous avez trouvé
votre bonheur ah bah oui totalement
franchement j'ai trouvé de la musique
haïtienne et
latino-américaine et donc si vous aussi
vous êtes intéressé par des vinyle
sachez que vous pouvez en trouver ici à
partir de 4
[Musique]
€